I've been telling this joke and my
stand-up which I told on I don't know
how dirty we can get you can get as
dirty as you want this is the Reuben
report and I'm still Dave Rubin before
we do anything else today we have
officially launched the Reuben report
community in the Apple App Store Google
Play and at Reuben report.com
but more importantly than that joining
me today is comedian podcaster and now
star of the new documentary no safe
spaces which is in theaters as of today
where we're taping this right now Adam
Carolla
welcome to Ruben report thank you Dave
good to have you here yeah you do it you
do a lot of this well I'm a fan of yours
but you do a lot of this the other way
you interview people all the time I do
and I enjoy being interviewed we like
more I well it's like well what do you
like more pizza or sushi well when you
eat a metric ton of pizza every month
you're dying for a California roll yeah
so so this is your California roll yeah
it's not that one is better than the
others like all I do is interview
interview interview and I like it when
it's swapped I also had this revelation
the other day which is I used to say to
dr. drew what you do is easy when we do
these shows we'd be guests on shows and
we do college campuses and we do
whatever and I realized when I had to be
funny it was a calorie burner and so
what happened was but my mic comparison
or contrast was this I've done a million
a million radio you know 25 stations
you're gonna talk to 25 stations over
the next three hours and it's the press
junket yeah and when I do one for my
book or a comedy that I'm in or
something of a comedic nature at the end
of the three hours I'm exhausted because
I'm trying to be funny the whole time
because it's a comedy book I'm telling
them jokes in the book I want them to
think I'm funny so the book is funny you
got to keep yourself entertained
yes although I don't care about myself
that much but yes I do but the last one
I did was over documentary not no safe
spaces but my Ford vs. Ferrari dock
which was Shelby American and the
24-hour war and all I was doing is
talking cars the whole time and shopped
the whole time and I was fresh as a
daisy after the three hours because I
realized I was talking about stuff I
knew
where's dr. drew gets to talk about
medicine if we just talked about
carpentry or cars I wouldn't be
exhausted if I'm spinning the comedic
plates it gets tiring what level of
energy do you have right now for me to
gauge how we should do this interview
then I never want to disappoint you so
or your are your fans our viewers so I'm
I'm putting out alright well we'll do a
little bit on the stuff you know and a
little bit on the stuff you pretend to
know how about that all up to you but
you kind of do do a zillion things
because your your account you consider
yourself a comic first right yes so your
comic your podcast your documentaries
reality shows do you sort of enjoy them
all the same or it's just kind of yeah
whatever I want to do whatever's next
you know I think I think what makes a
bad job for a bad job is monotony
repetition you know like if you have a
job where you go I work at a
medium-sized technology company and you
go okay that sounds okay but if you said
it's Owen I have a job where I work at a
conveyor belt I just put the heads on
dolls and they just keep it sounds
horrible right because it's the monotony
so if you think about it even hosting a
late-night show for 30 years is still
monotony within a good job you know and
so what most people don't like is when
they go he went to the same postal
sorting Center and Arleta for 50 years
and then he died ever feels because well
what a boring life but what a crappy
so for me doing a car doc doing a
free-speech doc doing a podcast writing
a book being in a TV show or whatever it
is it's all just variety and that's all
what that's all I want to do so we're
obviously going to talk a lot about no
safe spaces but your podcast you were
kind of early in on the podcast game and
your podcast is it basically the biggest
sort of talk comedy podcast like your
cut like you and Rogen it's hard to tell
so who's bigger do you know or you
measure in that number he's bigger on
iTunes but we don't get so much of our
listeners from iTunes so I don't know
I'll I'll just say he's bigger I'll be
magnanimous we were we're the New York
New York Times we're the Guinness Book
World Records are downloaded so that
much that much I know that was some
years ago so do you remember the moment
when you kind of wanted to make that
pivot to the digital thing because I saw
a lot of comics get all kinds of crossed
up people that had really promising
careers that still want it to go into TV
or traditional radio and then a lot
other guys were like no no there's
something else brewing here and then
they really started flourishing online
and I I think I kind of went that route
which is what we're doing here I had a
terrestrial radio job for many years
maybe over almost 15 years of
terrestrial radio straight-through that
ended abruptly I was only interested in
keeping a communication line between me
and my audience and not all of my
audience just some of my audience I was
always a big fan of talk radio
I was appreciated the format I always
like the connection that I felt like the
listeners were having with the hosts I
always knew it was deeper because there
was a sort of sense of loss that
transcended your favorite sitcom going
off the air you know last episode of
friends last episode Seinfeld
people are like ah last episode of
Breaking Bad
she was selling the air but when
somebody like Howard Stern hangs it up
there's got that ilk there's gonna be a
big sense of loss for people and not
just entertainment loss like emotional
loss so I had been doing Loveline and
doing a morning show with no commercials
and a lot of talk and and and I felt
like a real like I had an audience and I
had a connection and when my show air my
show ceased on a on a Friday I just said
whoever is listening if you want to come
with me to the digital world you may
find me and and I'm assuming most of you
aren't because you're in the car and the
tile and you're being passive and and so
if you're not you're not that's fine
like but that doesn't mean you need me
it means you don't care that much but
for the few that do want to keep going
down this road I can be found on the
Internet
come Monday so we won't even miss we
won't skip a day I'll stop on a Friday
you'll have me waiting for you on Monday
I'm not sure what form exactly yet but
you will get me and then we will try to
move forward from there and that was
really my only concern there was no
monetization that I was aware of back
then it was just sort of let's keep the
connection because it does feel like a
death when and I know from listening to
talk radio as a young person when
somebody finally signs an offer goes off
the air I'm like right there and in the
old days radio you were just gone right
that point right just because that's
been gone so I have not missed the day
since that date which was I think like
the 23rd of February like 2009 or
something
so you really were early on this and I
remember the first time I did your show
when I walked into your studio over
there I was like holy cow who's before I
had my home studio and everything and I
was like holy cow this guy actually has
a building and
staff and it's professional and there's
like an area to hang out coffee and you
know all your posters and everything I
was like oh you can really do this on
your own for me it was like whoa
all right great I there's a what there's
a path here well you're welcome so thank
you we'll clean that up in PO's yeah
yeah no post here no thing I'm not as
professional no post we're supposed to
host alright so I had this radio sort of
mind I had this thought where you want
to do a show you need a producer for
you're doing a show you need a sound guy
like you can't just completely mom and
pop this and expect it expect to get the
product that you want you know day in
and day out like you want some
production so my earliest thoughts were
I didn't have like I'm betting on myself
or I know this is gonna be bigger than
uber in five years or I didn't have any
of that I just had I know how radio
works
I don't see why this is different than
radio I don't know why we would treat it
any different we should have a staff we
should have a studio the equipment
should be good do don't be scared to
spend some money to get money you're
gonna have to spend it to make some like
any business and and like furthermore I
was kind of like if clients are coming
in or potential supporters or potential
folks are gonna buy ad time or whatever
it is they should walk into a building
that looks like their money's going
somewhere you know like it's that thing
of like you don't want your contractor
and I know that's a sore subject today
you're contra having a little contract
that gives you at the moment it's okay
the contractor pulls up in a total rust
bucket beater and then wants to charge
you a premium you're kind of like well
yeah look at your truck yeah I mean so
my thing is like get a nice truck get a
nice bed box get a lumber rack like tuck
your shirt in look look like you're good
contractor and then charge then go ahead
and gouge the elderly
you're like the Jordan Peterson of
contractors basically all right you're
telling them to clean their room you
must be very impressed with my lighting
grid though it is I mean come on that is
a professional expensive lighting grid
right there it really is it really is
nice you'll love this the guy who hung
this whole entire grid which these are
huge you can imagine how heavy all these
poems are and everything I didn't know
who he was I got referred to him by a
friend a guy shows up my night door he's
about 60 years old I swear on my life
his arms in a sling he's wearing a Tommy
Bahama shirt and flip-flops he goes I'm
Joe I'm here to hang the grid and he did
this entire thing basically with one arm
and flip-flops 15-foot high ceilings
with the system of pulleys that he
created with one arm on a 15 foot ladder
with flip-flops 60 year old guy it was
incredible people don't realize people
work hard you know I listen I come from
the construction world so I understand
working hard and I also understand that
the number one killer of men over
ladders in flip-flops they ladders and
flip-flops it's not a good not a good
combination all right let's talk about
this movie no safe spaces because I felt
when I watched it a couple weeks ago I
went to the premiere here in LA and you
were there and you did this with Dennis
Prager and Jordan Peterson was in it and
Lindsey Shepherd was in it and Brett
Weinstein was in it and had their high
and was in it basically I felt it was
like a Reuben rapport reunion show I was
very pleased but there was one guy in it
that I thought was really incredible and
I want to throw to a clip there's a
reason that every time one of these
professors or TAS whether it's Lindsey
Shepherd in Canada or Brett Weinstein in
Washington why are they all lefties who
then say one thing that upsets the left
and then they're purged it will come for
you I mean that that's if there if
there's someone that's watching this
right now that is a hardcore progressive
that's going man I hate fragrant Ruben
and this is all nonsense guess what if
you have any spark of in
visual ISM in you if you have any
anything about you that's interesting or
different they will come to destroy that
to that guy is incredible
yeah he's got it yeah I it I'm sure
they're gonna spin that guy off and do
some series there's no way they continue
down this path with Prager and Corolla
when they got that yeah why why did you
do this movie
where'd this all come from you know
contrary to popular anything for me as
we're kind of discussing off the air I
like experiences and the answer is
usually yes like people say to me why
did you do Dancing with the Stars I'm
like they asked and like yeah but what
made you want to do and I just went oh
actually with the answer the stars they
asked me if I want to do it I thought oh
I'm scared like my first impulse was
like it's like Amy Bobby Hinton wants to
see you in the alley after the seventh
grade you went like oh oh my god I'm
scared like I'm scared and then you
realized oh I have to fight as I look
I'm scared like that's what I felt and I
like Praeger I've had a chance to travel
around play some colleges or do some
events with him Praeger is a great guy
just to kind of kick around with because
he's you you know he has all the wisdom
and the knowledge but in this kind of
jovial sort of Uncle Joe from petticoat
junction kind of fun way but also is
this fountain of wisdom and knowledge
and there's really no better guy like I
mean I have been lucky in that you know
hanging out with Jimmy Kimmel hanging
out with dr. Drew hanging out with
Dennis Prager like just sitting next to
him on a long flight or something like
there's no better guys to just talk or
laugh or exchange ideas with all
different but they're like great and I
love that like I
of sitting with someone and just hearing
their ideas and sharing ideas so so when
they said we want to do this movie and
dennis prager doing it i was just kind
of like oh good more time to hang out
with dennis prager I mean I like the
theme and I and I and I like you know if
you say to me we want you to be involved
with this product or project and we're
not gonna tell you what to say you you
give your opinions on stuff I'm usually
in like I'm usually in if you go say
whatever you want if you say like we're
doing this project here's a script
memorize it regurgitate it I'm usually
like I'm not that interested in that but
you're gonna sit with Praeger we're
gonna bring up subjects you guys are
gonna sort of tag-team those subjects
and I'm like I'm in so the movie mostly
is about the college campus sort of
upheaval that's going on right now do
you remember when you first sort of were
aware that there was the problem I was
hearing from other comedians that they
didn't want to go to college campuses I
was you know like anyone seeing in the
news when people were going to speak at
college campuses and unable to speak I
live in this world where it's like
mostly comedy world so I have this
bizarre world where I'm good friends
with Sarah Silverman but I'm also
friends with Ben Shapiro you know so I
would hear these bits and pieces and
people saying to me like I remember like
backstage of The Comedy Store like Sarah
said to me your joke that joked that
black joke you have she's like so funny
like too bad you can't do it you know
that's like wow that sucks it's weird
that comedians are saying to other
comedians like hey it's a great joke too
bad you can't do it oh you what do you
really make of that though cuz so I'm
not a fan of Sarah as I've invited her
on the show many times to me she's sort
of you know I don't
make this about your friends
specifically so you don't have to answer
directly to her but like there's a
series of comics now that we're really
politically incorrect back in the day
like she's been in blackface right
Jimmy's been at Jimmy Kimmel's been in
blackface I don't think either one of
them are racist but by the rules that
the left is setting which they kind of
are about those rules right now she's
saying to you oh don't make that black
joke anymore and there's a lot of that
happening with comics and I never would
have expected that with comedians well
if you think about comedians she the
thing about comedians at their core that
want to be loved right like they're
you're standing on stage kind of saying
like please please love me it I mean
like they weren't the most popular kids
they weren't jocks in high school like
they want if you think about like why
are comedians like they're very
sensitive which is counterintuitive you
know what I mean like Jeff Ross the
roastmaster
it's a super sensitive guy and I don't
mean that like in a weak way but he's
he's nothing like the roastmaster he's a
sweet sensitive guy many comedians are
sensitive many comedians want to be
loved many actors want to be loved
that's the profession they're not taking
the job of Staff Sergeant or Foreman
they're doing it you have a job that
goes like please accept me please love
me so when these matters come down the
pike there are Oh what would get people
to love me and accept me and embrace me
and send out positive tweets and vibes
and stuff so they are sort of wrestling
with this duality of I speak my mind I
tell it like it is
I take no prisoners please love me
please love that's a freaking fine line
it's a pretty weird fine line yeah my
thing has always been I know I'm not an
[ __ ] so I am now free to act like an
[ __ ]
hmm like I know like my whole thing is
like I know I'm not a bad person so I
can say whatever I want sort of uh if
you have it it's it's basically this if
you if you have friends who you know
they love you and you know you love them
then you let the ballbusting begin if
you have somebody if you think about it
psychologically like there's that person
there's always that one person at work
where there's like five of you want to
go to lunch and then there's Andy if you
don't really want Andy to come with you
but if Andy ever catches wind
you have to like overcompensate and then
he's gonna I don't know I think I'm just
gonna eat at my desk and everywhere it
wouldn't be lunch without your brother
and it's like what they're doing is they
all feel weird and bad for not wanting
to be there that they actually go the
other way yeah but if you love Andy and
Yandy loves you then you go we'll get
you a burger bring it back maybe I'll
take a bite out of it and then he laughs
and then you laugh and then he ends up
going but I feel that way about making
fun of groups or races or individuals or
anything if you're you have some kind of
darkness in your heart like I always say
you know how you know I'm not racist I
make so many racist jokes
I was racist I'd be like I don't make
any more racist jokes are on to you do
you think there's some element of it
though with comics where it's like the
ones that have done some of that stuff
in the past now it's like they have to
pay penance to make sure that their past
doesn't destroy them where you're saying
your guilt free because you've done some
stuff right like do you ever worry that
like they're gonna you know go back in
the man show clips and be oh he hates
women or any of this kind of stuff but
what they're doing is sort of a more
dangerous game because again I don't
want to make it about those two people
specifically but like there's a series
of comics now in public people that are
calling everyone racists and bigots and
all the Conservatives are bad guys I
mean you know to
all right and it's like well you guys
used to do that stuff you know and it
just it strikes me as just it's just
self-preservation I get the emotionally
damaged part but it just strikes me as
like it's just business in a way well I
mean look there there it is a business
in that it's a it's it's a business
where we don't need man let me put it
this re to drop but let me but let me
put it this way so if you showed us if
there was a thing that 20 years ago you
showed up in blackface I don't think you
would get the past that say Kimmel's
gotten because Kimmel is a big lefty now
he's a Hollywood lefty so he gets a pass
right where you are
you're more libertarian conservative or
just sort of out there so that you now
you're also self-funded so that helps
right like you're your own boss so
that's good but yeah but you wouldn't
get the past you do you agree with that
here's what I here's my take on it I
think they go where the getting's good
so they're basically feral cats looking
for a saucer of milk and if you don't
put it out on the porch they'll kind of
keep going people don't really bother me
even though I say horrible things and
not horrible things but my definition
but by their definition yeah I do have a
picture me in blackface it's going it's
mr. t and how for Halloween in like 1985
I put it out there I'm like look listen
this isn't blackface this is mr. T
that's not blackface yeah that's a
minstrel show yeah this is me dressing
like mr. t because I'm a fan of mr. T's
so this is it's the normal thoughtful
way of dealing with this of course you
weren't doing it to mock the guy you
were doing it out of admiration and love
right and you would like to take it and
contort it and twist it into blackface
which is sort of general generic make
fun of black people vaudeville stuff
this is not that so first things first
I'm not signing off on your definition
what I did yeah I dressed up as mr. t
mr. t is black I went with a black face
which is not black face it's me dressing
as mr. t and furthermore I'm not
apologizing to anybody about it and if
you talk to mr. t I bet he would be
happy than a bunch of kids dressed like
him in 1985 and said I pity the fool ya
over and over again at a Halloween party
by mr. t cereal that's far worse
blackface of mr. Jane sumed mr. T's no I
think with me then really there's no job
to remove me from per se and then also I
don't apologize and I also the other
thing is is I don't let or I attempt not
to let people create this narrative and
create this theme which is you know you
there's a picture of you with black it
wasn't paint I actually took a shot I
took up I think I took a toilet paper
roll and burnt the end of it and then
like smeared that suet on my face but
there's a picture of you in blackface
and I go no no there's a picture of me
dressed like mr. t and they go in
blackface I go not blackface that's a
different genre
this is mr. t that's from the 40s of the
30s this is from the eighties but you
still I know
I've just said mr. T it's an homage to
the man and what do you want me to do
about all I'll put every picture up on
the internet I don't care yeah are you
kind of fascinated how it hits like
every comic no matter how sort of
vanilla they are there's a moment it's
in the movie about Seinfeld telling this
story about doing a college gig and he
does a joke about again what is it a gay
British king or something I was with her
French King with a loose hand and he's
and he said he did this joke and the
kids basically it's like five years ago
the kids basically you know groaned
right it's like Seinfeld who I love
Jerry stand-up the shows the greatest
hit come ever it's like I don't know any
of his political beliefs on anything
like he is so guarded what his actual
beliefs are and he does this silly joke
about a French king's hand and that's
even too politically incorrect for these
students yeah you know it's it's funny
I've now kind of figured it's kind of
interesting because I do know a lot of
these comedians and we've we all know
our actors or Hollywood community
I've now kind of figured it out where
you went like well I know Sarah
Silverman and Mark Ruffalo and Alyssa
Milano I know their politics you know
but I don't know Jerry Seinfeld's
politics or I don't know Jay Leno's
politics I go ahead and check the
Republican box because my new theory I
started thinking about and I have some
insider trading information you're like
how come everyone else is out there
blasting it out from the highest
mountain I mean when you're on the left
and you're not playing it close to the
vest like a Morano
it's a Dennis Prager reference but the
the Jews of Spain who are kind of like
don't let anyone find if you are if you
are back in Bernie or Elizabeth Warren
or whatever and you're in the Hollywood
community you have a bullhorn there on a
mountaintop so if you really just kind
of do the reverse math like who are the
people whose politics you're completely
unaware of and you've never heard them
speak a word about it you must go hmm
how come I've never heard how come I've
never seen them at a rally right women's
rally or marching on or sending it to
eat out about and you go I'm gonna do a
reverse math on that mm-hmm
so you're saying Seinfeld ain't voting
for Bernie I think the guys who you hear
nothing about yeah have a have a leaning
that's probably a little less Bernie and
probably a little
or Trump do you miss the days when not
everything was so political because that
also is what this movie is about and
that politics has now leaked into every
part of society all the time so it's
like you just mentioned Leno and it's
like back in the day like I never really
liked Leno because I didn't know what he
thought about anything and in a weird
way I miss that now like I don't watch
any of those late-night shows but every
night you when you see clips on Twitter
of I can't even think of who's the host
who's the who's the foul and foul who's
the other way NBC where the other guy
Seth Meyers it's like they're just
railing on Trump every like it's the
same thing every night over and over
where it's so political all the time and
it's made me sort of miss the day that
Leno would just go up there it was just
like he was just doing this thing that
was sort of for everybody yeah you know
I think there's an element of a sort of
a saturation point like you did one Leno
back in the day to dig into more
substantive issues or reveal a little
more of himself and and all that and Jay
who I know really well is always
realized that this is a marathon and
it's not a sprint I respect that now I
regret I was hard on him for years when
I was doing stand-up and I regret it
actually and I think he's kind of
realized that no good could come from
him I also believe I believe there's
some old-school comedians who go you're
not supposed to know me you're supposed
to know my jokes hmm like I'm gonna let
my jokes do my talking I don't want the
distraction of you knowing Republican or
Democrat or gay or straight or anything
like I don't want anything bleeding into
this this joke these jokes I'm going to
lay over you but also when people know
you know when you take a stand as a as a
Patriots fan and he let the world
you're the number one Patriot in the
Patriots are capable of then spending a
decade lose it right like you know like
why declare a major when the next person
could get voted in and this thing could
swing like the other direction it seems
like you're putting your career
needlessly in jeopardy that's kind of
crazy for a comic that truth-telling
thing and the like thing they can often
just be at odds with each other yeah I
do think that many people many comedians
as you know just have a different
approach to comedy and and also there's
an element of you you live in Hollywood
you have you have a job I've been I've
been telling this joke and my standup
which I told on I don't know how dirty
we can get you can get as dirty as you
want I told this joke when we were doing
the you want to get in blackface for
this one with a guy with some charcoal
back here we're doing a roast on Comedy
Central for Alec Baldwin and it's a joke
that Larry David was sitting in the
front row and any literally on a
commercial break like came over and what
that's the funniest thing I've ever
heard I was like the great as well
because I love pretty pretty pretty good
like he literally then I was like like
that joke I love it and it's it's a very
Larry David joke all right
and it's also totally politically
incorrect but it is here to kind of
illustrate that mm-hmm
when I was a carpenter or guys who do
fabrication work and can shape metal
into any shape or a guy in flip-flops
with one arm who can hang a lighting
grid it doesn't really matter what his
politics are we can't run him out mm-hmm
we can't go no more lighting grid work
for you or hey man if your journeyman
carpenter like like your good carpenter
you can't be drummed out yeah there's
like too many people who need you if
you're an actor look this man
flower made 30 million dollars a year
now Matt Lauer makes nothing's then when
Miss Matt Lauer right we don't need Matt
Lauer we didn't need Billy Bush like we
must knock it out and go with somebody
else and we don't need you and that's
kind of scary you live in a town where
the journeyman carpenter don't have to
have to worry what they talked about but
an actor you could get tossed out of
this club and the joke was I had Alec
Baldwin sitting over here and I had
Robert De Niro sitting next to him and I
said two of the finest actors in America
what amazing craft and an ability
unbelievable ability look look at the
two of you I mean maybe the two greatest
ever so much respect for you but
actually hearing after hearing about the
whole Harvey Weinstein situation and
here in a lot of those stories I don't
know if I have such high respect for the
craft of acting anymore I mean what
other job works this way you want to be
a commercial airline pilot yeah blow
that fat you this afternoon
below the fat you know like you can
start tomorrow that's like I was making
the joke that maybe acting is not as I
think that proves your point right so
actors are in a precarious situation now
Dave Chappelle isn't mm-hmm Dave
Chappelle's a journeyman carpenter
mm-hmm but Matt Lauer reads a
teleprompter and many actors could be
replaced by whenever they do those
things you know who was gonna play the
original Indiana Jones and you go oh it
was gonna be you know double-oh-seven
was gonna be yeah all right do you guys
do you realize they live in a world
where someone else could just take their
job the next day and we're not really
gonna miss them so you got to kind of
follow the party line it's interesting
that you bring up Chappelle because
you're basically saying a guy like him
who has just relentlessly you know
fought the system sort of his bravery is
what now protects him with that that
kind of is a theme throughout the movie
to that all of the people that I meant
earlier from from Brett and Lindsey and
Jordan who else is in I mean just
everybody's in there you know there's
there's Van Jones and Jones and there's
Dershowitz well that's so that's
interesting because you guys make a
point and this this is the part that I
mean you make a point of saying but
there are a couple liberals left did you
feel like that was like a point you
really had to hit otherwise you would
just be seen as you know a couple good
liberals left as opposed to just saying
well then we're just making a
conservative movie here or something
like well I think you know I think
there's kind of a catch-22 where like
someone will say and and then there's
obviously been this critique you're only
highlighting right-leaning speakers or
conservative speakers who are being
shouted off the college campuses you're
only highlighting the bench of Parros
and the Ann Coulter's and the answer is
because they don't shout off any and
they'll shout out left-leaning one so
you're this is a weird thing you're
asking us to do like be more even-handed
well if Rachel Maddow went to Berkeley
there wouldn't be fires in the parking
lot so yeah you mean it wouldn't cost
what was it was a three or six hundred
thousand to secure that Shapiro event I
owned by six I think it was six I think
so yeah this thing of like we only
highlight this well it's like those
older people get protested so if you're
gonna highlight protests then
unfortunately it's only gonna be from
that side we wanted to I mean we've had
conversations we don't want this to come
across as some sort of right-wing
tutorial yeah and it does we wanted the
van Joneses and the Cornel West and the
alan dershowitz I and many people from
all sides and all everything in between
to speak about this this subject and and
that was intentional you you link a lot
of this stuff that's happening on
colleges in the movie you link it to
sort of how we've raised kids now so you
want to want to kick the Millennials
while they're down I do I do as I as I
travel through this line
and I think I think the self-esteem
movement has really is really the
genesis of this we started because I
started thinking like when I was 19 I
didn't have any self-esteem and my thing
was like I'm not gonna tell an adult
what to do like I would never dream if I
was walking down the street and I was
like 16 and I passed a 45 year old guy
and he's one heystop not well I need to
go give me 20 push-ups
okay diamond hands or we've gotta do a
wide spread like I would have just done
it because he's a dude he's older than
me and he told me to do something that's
how I was wired so I started thinking
like well if I were 19 and I was on a
college campus and I was on a
construction site but if I was on a
college campus and by the way when I was
on a construction site I had a foreman
go he said go to my truck get my four
foot level out of my gun rack yeah like
a four foot level hang a nice gun rack
and I said okay and I started walking a
truck and he goes hey run and I started
running because he told me to run he's
older than I am and it was like a gun
rack so it was probably wise
yeah where's the gun here run it
probably wasn't all levels in their
running serpentine so I started thinking
if I was 19 and I was on a college
campus and they announced that some 50
year old with a bunch of degrees was
coming to speak I wouldn't ever go like
not a over my dead body I just be like
okay all right and then someone would go
well Adam he's gonna talk about stuff
you disagree with and I'd go well he's
50 and has all the degrees so I guess
I'm probably wrong and then someone
would go dude does he have the right to
speak here and I go course it's not my
campus I'm just I'm basically this is a
four-year motel I'm living at I don't
own the building like
who know about something for me too and
then if they went
we're gonna go rally and make them
create a human blockade I'd be like why
what just don't go to the show well I
don't I don't get it and I realize sort
of like a sane functioning person that's
what you're saying you would have acted
like a that should be well how high does
your self-esteem have to be to go not on
my watch
no way is is David Rubin or Jordan SR
Jordan Rubin are they bench the
parasites combining all these people by
him in the woods
what marble transforming yeah that's
gonna be protested why would why why
would that be my job Who am I to do that
so if you think about what that takes
that takes a life of grooming that takes
a life of don't let anyone tell you what
to do you tell them what to do like
you're special your opinion matters
don't let anybody you know how serve the
self-esteem movement I believe is super
dangerous I mean how you gonna put world
war ii get in a higgins landing craft
and go hit normandy nineteen-year-olds
with super high self esteem you think
they're getting in that thing
you think they're gonna rush out of
german pillbox hell no no so this thing
that we thought was good like hey what
if everyone just felt really good about
themselves like that's good if you earn
it if you just rub it on them
that ain't earning it and that's gonna
lead to trouble so if we go a little
meta on that do you think that's
actually by design do you think that is
just like it's sort of just kind of like
liberals that wanted everybody to feel
good and it's just kind of nice or do
you think it was actually by designed by
some some bad actors that push this
stuff out there to to weaken all of the
things that that the movies about I
think it can be traced back to a
gentleman who's out of Los Angeles who
had an idea which is like it was an all
paraphrase but it's like some of these
inner-city kids and some of these
low-income kids or single-parent kids
and stuff they have low self-esteem but
they don't their dad abandoned them look
they don't feel good about themselves
and if they felt good about themselves
they would start excelling in school and
get out of gangs and not be involved
with crime so how do we get them to feel
good about themselves and it's like well
we can't get their dad back in the house
and we can't give him an A in calculus
when they're failing calculus we're just
going to start telling them how good
they are and they'll feel good about
themselves and whatever happening is it
turns out like criminals have high self
esteem no it's a unintended circumstance
like I have a good heart you know it's
basically all that stuff of like I have
a good heart
let's build big housing projects and let
people live in free in those and we'll
give them food and we'll level it's like
yeah you're good it all sounds good you
have a great heart
you've now ruined a group of people
that's how you ruin people you you tell
them you give them things without
earning it you give them food without
earning it you give them housing without
earning it or you give them self-esteem
without earning it you don't earn it it
doesn't work it morphs into something
bad and then comes back in a weird kind
of vitriolic way so one of the things I
kept thinking during the movie is over
the last couple years I've had all these
people on I mean so many of the people
in the movie or have been in here to
discuss the very things they're they're
bringing up in the movie I've often
thought and am i over blowing this like
am I am I just exaggerating or am I just
finding these random people Lindsay
Shepard this.ta at Wilfrid Laurier
University in Canada which I had never
heard of before am i over blowing this
and and then the answer always turned
out to be no because the next week
there's somebody else that it happens to
in the next week there's somebody else
and the rest of it but were you ever
worried about that that as you make this
that it
makes it feel like it's bigger than it
is or do you really believe that it is
this big I think when you when you
endeavor to do any kind of storytelling
there's a balance between making it
compelling and I know this I'll give you
an example and then I'll circle back
I've made other documentaries about
subjects that have nothing to do with
this and I made a documentary about Paul
Newman and his racing life and it's
called winning the racing life of Paul
Newman and you're your audience would
enjoy it
his partner his teammate and his like
best friend and teammate died in a race
in Florida Paul was racing he was racing
Fitzie was his name he died in the race
he died they think because he had a
heart attack when he was driving the car
and just never slowed down for like turn
three and just plowed in the walls and
died and when you're making the film I'm
saying it's more dramatic if he just
never hit the brakes on turn three and
gotten this horrific accident and died
now the truth is he had a heart attack
probably and died and then hit the wall
and died for sure or broke his neck or
whatever it is and as a filmmaker I'm
like I don't want to lie but I'd like to
make this dramatic so I took out the
part where he probably was dead from the
heart attack and just said he went down
the straightaway he never break four
turn three he died when he hit the wall
you know and so there's this kind of
thing where it's like don't lie but
you're also making a film like you're
trying to entertain I I think what's
going on on college campuses is bad I
have 13 year old twins I have
reservations about sending them to
college and I do hear the stories and I
don't like this
but on this by the same token you're
trying to make a film that holds
people's interest and the music swells
of you at you take a little artistic
license and it's a dramatic shot of the
smoke burning in slow motion and stuff
and yeah so of course there's an element
of like we are gonna massage it you know
like they do in in the you know in
theatrical filmmaking as well there's
it's speaking to the same party brain
like you want people to sit up pay
attention and and what-have-you and it's
just a part of filmmaking so the answer
is sort of yes and yes I do think it's
bad but also you take some artistic
license and Ratchet it up right and you
guys actually hit all that because there
are moments where you're it's like my
heart was like kind of tight like oh man
this is horrible and then a minute later
you're laughing so it like it does kind
of feel that when you see people like I
thought there's an extensive portion on
what happened to Bret Weinstein and his
wife Heather at at Evergreen and as I
was watching it and I know Bret very
well now and we're good friends I was
kind of thinking like wow how did he not
see this coming
like as a lefty professor at a leftie
school did you did you think that at all
about how did these guys not see that
this thing was just brewing all this
time like until the day before the kids
are showing up with the baseball bats on
campus well I think there's a I think
there's a disconnect i-i've had this
thought all the time like when I it's
like your auntie I've you know this is a
big thing with like dr. Drew it's like
there's a whole anti-smoking collation
out and coalition so there's an
anti-smoking Cola said we hate smoke
secondhand smoke third hand smoke
there's no place for smoke and then
somebody goes okay we now have vaping
it's just a vapor with nicotine which is
sort of inert with vapor and that's like
basically saying caffeine and water so
good we're happy now right they go
now now let's outlaw that there you go
hold on I thought you didn't like smoke
thank ya no we don't we don't and you
start to kind of realize some groups
like pitas that way the anti-smoking
people are that way there's a right
version of that when I did Loveline it
was like Christian Coalition you know
they're against abortions oh okay good
now they have the morning-after pill and
then go yeah we're getting set to wait
away that's gonna stop abortion so they
go yeah we're not we're not down with
that pill and you're like wait you hate
abortions yes there's a pill you can
take that stops then cementation it's
like yeah we don't want that yeah like
okay okay so now I'm starting to think
you just won control my favorite one of
those is Peter Thiel who's the openly
gay billionaire out magazine wrote a
piece on him that he's not gay actually
because he's conservative right and that
would that would trump his gayness right
deal with gay or black anything like I
can't sell it she's not black enough
right cuz I love it I love the hypocrisy
and I realize that the group the sort of
progressive movement if you really just
take those two words progress and
movement it's like this is saying we
don't stop but we keep rolling and so I
think like Weinstein guys like that go
they take things at face value like okay
they want a day without black students
say okay I get it that's a tradition
like I see what they want they want this
thing and it's like no they don't want
this thing they want to keep going and
they want to keep telling you what to do
and once they get what they want for a
while it's never know once ever appears
right we don't we don't go okay we could
move on guys time to move on we're know
they go who's next
what's next what can we do so this day
without a black student thing what the
worst thing you can do is just go okay
good for you we applied that they go
okay and then they go wait a minute
there's nothing there push against the
man has basically endorsed this right
and Brett
for the record he did endorse it for
daddy there he said if you guys don't
want to come on this data to protest
what you view as historic discrimination
go ahead and do it but then you get
bored with red right now so then they
ran it on someone what to do so now you
Ratchet it up and then Brett Weinstein
is like he doesn't get it because he's
seeing it through the eyes of a sane
person like not basically that's all of
our fatal flaws in this huh well the
reason the Twin Towers are on the ground
is because we did a thing of like wait a
minute who would fly an airplane into a
building if they were in the airplane
like you would parachute out of the
airplane like no no I'll be the pilot
I'll be the first to hit the building
and we go well no one would do that like
I could see them putting a truck bomb
and running but they're gonna go fly it
in well they're all of them are in the
airplane is that see we don't think that
way like that doesn't make sense than us
you have to realize there's a lot of
people out there that think in a way
that is totally different than the way
you think and by the way when you think
you think it's a universal thing that
you like when you say to me some people
don't like lasagna like Oh get the [ __ ]
out it ok people that's not true
everyone loved society I bigger some
people don't care for it I go no way
yeah unless I sign it I so they don't
think like I think and they don't like
lasagna and I can't picture that but you
don't fly a plane to their home you're
telling me that's what I'm saying
fly commercial airliner into their home
so I'm saying I think guys like Brett
Weinstein is is saying well I think
illogically and I love everyone and I'm
open-minded and I'm liberal so no one
could go after me after all I teach at
this school and people know my
reputation and I
a little bit of a jew-fro I ride my twin
in everyday like come on I'm on this
groups that going after me I'm on them
man so he's thinking and what he's not
realizing is that group can go after
anybody because they're never satiated
there's no finish line they're just
going to keep going
has that sold you on conservatism more
so now cuz I see that as you know I
still describe myself as liberal but I
see this as like the real sort of almost
unsolvable problem of liberalism that
liberals always want to be open and
decent and understanding and all of that
but then when a movement that is so
totalitarian and crazed and and wants to
progress no matter what it's progressing
to liberals don't seem to have a good
defense against that where conservatives
seem to actually have it better well I
feel like I've never felt like I've
never felt it practical to pick a team
and then pick all that is that team and
and so I'll I'll answer in a roundabout
way I I love cars I have a bunch of race
cars
I Drive a bunch of race cars I have a
lot of different cars like because I
love cars and you know sometimes I'll
talk to guys and they'll go I'll go oh
they'll go you're a car guy I'm a car
guy like you love cars I love cars and
then I go what kind of cars do you like
and they go I'm a Mopar guy everything I
got to dodge everything's got a Hemi in
it everything's and I'm like well you're
a car guy but you just have this one car
it's kind of like going I love the
ladies but only Porter it's like hop on
a blonde and a black chick and a redhead
like if you really love women what's
wrong with all of you know all of them
you know like that's right thing it's
like if you really love women go out
with a whole bunch of different women
and I feel now I finally believe
you're not racist there you go you're
willing to bang every type of thing
that's never had woman yeah the the and
I sort of treat my world politically
kind of like I'm just pushing a cart
through a Trader Joe's like I'm not
really into the Nilla cookies over there
but I do like that jerky you know and I
at some point the cart will start to
take shape I guess and you'll go oh this
guy likes his meat or he likes his
protein or this person likes their carb
carbohydrates or whatever and so for me
it's like conservative well I'm not
religious I'm basically an atheist and
I'm not a gun person but I'm not anti
God I'm sort of pragmatic gun I've sort
of realized like when you read op-eds
and the Los Angeles Times about should
we arm the teachers what difference
would it make if one of those teachers
at Columbine had a gun
what difference and then they go they go
three kids dead eight kids dead fifteen
what's the difference I'm like what's
the difference the difference is three
versus 15 but so like I didn't make a
pretty big difference to the fourth kid
who would have died if the teacher
wasn't armed so it's like I'm not buying
into this cockamamie doctrine of what
difference would it make
but my thing is like I'm not religious
and I I don't have real strong like sort
of conservative whatever upbringing or
values but I do understand that intact
families and a focus on education and
having a patriotic the patriotic part
just sort of loving your country not to
the point where you know you've covered
yourself in the American flag and
driving a pickup truck but I mean like
appreciating your country like going
okay we've made mistakes but you know
what is there anywhere else you'd rather
live you know like that leads to a sort
of happiness and pot legal gay marriage
legal whatever else do
our own thing I'm not I'm very
interested in if I'm not hurting you I
should be able to do what I want to do
and if you're but but the problem with
the left is the left is saying let us
tell you what to do and if you say
something that we have not vetted or
approved we shall remove you from your
job and that kind of McCarthyism of no
one can work because you had a
transgression from eleven years ago in a
yearbook or whatever it is I don't like
in the part that I really don't like and
the part that's feeling very sort of
like Communist China to me is like the
forced apologies that's the scary part
to me like the announcer that is talking
about the Baltimore Ravens quarterback
and it's like well he's skin tone as
dark the ball is dark that jerseys dark
he has an advantage that at some point
he has to go I regret saying and realize
that my hurtful terms looks like you
don't regret it
these weren't hurtful terms we want you
to analyze football and you've actually
brought up a point I've never thought of
which is it takes a millisecond for the
outside linebacker who's coming around
the corner you're trying to get him to
bite on this play fake you're trying and
just as if I was a if I was an
african-american boxer and I had brown
gloves that I kept them close to my
chest and you had red gloves I'd have a
little advantage I could see I could see
the red gloves coming a millisecond off
of versus the brown gloves off of the
brown skin color and this guy was
basically making the point that at the
defensive end and then he went on to say
how great the quarterback was so he's
making a point it's an interesting point
and he's right even the guy can't the
guy does a great job of staying with it
the balls hard to spot the outside
linebacker fights on it and he goes he
goes around him for a touchdown and he
has to pretend to apologize
because he's going to get fired and when
I hear to me the heartbreaking part of
the whole thing
is the apology yeah at the outrage
culture and on it it's the person with
the prepared statement begging for you
not to relieve them of their job that's
the part that feels like Twilight Zone
wish you out to the cornfield like hey
hey it's a good thing it's a real good
thing boy it's a good thing you did like
everyone's scared to get wished out into
the cornfield and now they're having to
apologize and there's so many crazy
examples that remember when Mark Duplass
seems the Hollywood producer and actor
who's been on my show
he's we're friendly and he said he sent
out that tweet that he basically said
Ben Shapiro is not the devil and then he
had to apologize like it's like he
didn't endorse the guy he didn't say you
agree with it was in effect like he's
not a horrible person and then you know
no it's it's it's like Orwell in but
it's also McCarthyism yeah it's like you
look III know the de playa is they're
good guys yeah that was largely good
work they they're they live now the only
way to stomp this out is for everyone to
tell everyone to [ __ ] off and not do it
but the marked applause does shows with
HBO
they're very woke this may not hurt him
but are you taking that chance I mean
you got a production company wife and
kids employees you got a business you
know what I mean and what he's doing is
he's going me saying ben shapiro is a
good guy even if i preface it with it
you may not agree yeah there's a hole
however and then getting a bunch of
blowback maybe HBO it doesn't think
about that yeah maybe they don't I have
25 employees so I want to take that
chance I don't want to take that chance
so I'm just gonna issue this cowardly
statement basically distancing myself
from a guy who helped me out I mean it's
completely disingenuous it's it's
cowardly
and but but hey I got a job I got to
keep my job like this
that's great so now you and I don't have
have that or maybe it's not helping your
I I don't know
I don't care yeah if we want to work for
HBO you want to sell product HBO you
better be careful what you say who you
associate with and who you do business
with or who you praised alright so the
last thing so we can wrap up with the
movie oh yeah you talked about that
Praeger guy before there's a sort of fun
moment in the movie where you talk about
how different you guys are like you just
everything about you you just said
you're basically an atheist you know
he's a at least somewhat religious you
you're up rings are completely different
everything about you guys completely
different yet you guys came together on
this thing and you were touring in
colleges before this and all that can
you talk about that a little bit well
you know I think we do a thing which is
you see how I brought it around so that
you could promote the movie I do love
that wasn't that professional knows
insiders you also got a chassis chass
why.com and see all these motor racing
docks I've made if you like that I don't
like this world I was just talking about
this yesterday where it's like we need
diversity and people of color and the
and the fire department should represent
the community than it that it serves and
it's all that and it's like well so what
your skin color is the same color like
what what really is that you're the same
yeah you know what I mean like Dennis
and I have common sense
he has buckets of common sense I'm very
rooted in common sense we have nothing
in common but we do have common sense
and that trumps everything and we have
somehow constructed a world where you go
your mom's name is Dorothy my mom's name
is Dorothy
Wow now we really have a bond
have a bond and you go you're from
Valley Village I grew up in value it so
what you don't have a bond your skin
color let's just give you a bond mm-hmm
your height your you love oh the rams
are your team I love their what what the
hell kind of bond is that the real
diversity is having different thoughts
and different ideas and the real kinship
is sharing common sense and ideas and in
thinking alike
obviously nobody could get further away
from my background than Dennis Prager he
is you know
devout you speak five languages traveled
to every kind in the world
and most every country is a scholar is
everything I'm from you know four and a
half miles that way who grew up riding
BMX bikes and working on construction
sites working as a boxing coach is it
took growling Groundlings classes
there's no education no understanding of
symphonic scores no anything except for
we have a total kinship because with
this sort of common sense clarity I
think I would count you in that group as
well I don't feel I'm sure you and I are
extremely different in our upbringing in
our lifestyle but I feel it a definite
clarity and a kinship with you because
of that common sense clarity and I think
people make a mistake where they go oh
well you're just a Republican or you're
just of this or you're just at that no
to me people think clearly or they don't
think clearly it doesn't mean they're
right a hundred percent of the time it's
that they want to get to it and you know
famously when you were sitting down with
larry elder all those years ago they're
talking about race here we go
and he brought up a bunch of stats and
facts and stuff and you said you didn't
say cut you didn't say I agree to
disagree you didn't do that thing where
you go like oh yeah I'm gonna pull the
real stats and I'll get back to you
Monday and you'll apologize me and then
never get back to or whatever you
stopped and when well maybe there's
something I can learn from this person
and
we'll be I will be open to it and I was
like now II respect you I respect you
and and so in this conversation where
Larry elders shooting out all these
facts and figures
I find myself respecting you I'm saying
because he's open to this he's he's not
going a lot of sounds was that wrong
he's going
I will leave myself in this receptive
position and if I hear things that make
sense I'll give I'll think about it I'm
not gonna ward off of everything because
you're on that side and I'm on this side
you know it's funny I just thought
that's what you're supposed to do as a
human like it's not rocket science I
just thought Oh someone's telling me
something this stuff sounds pretty good
I'll check it out
right that was it I always love when
Prager says I don't need agreement I
just need clarity like we just I need to
understand what you're saying and you
need to understand what I'm saying and
usually if you're both intelligent
people you'll arrive and if there's not
a bunch of underlying issues about you
know being in with the school teachers
unions or something like that you'll
just all arrive kind of at the same
place but that's yes that's how you're
supposed to be that's how you should be
it's called being intellectually honest
and I wish more people on the right and
the left we're that way and it would
behoove you to be that way because
that's the way you grow and change and
evolve all right cool I've never done
this in the history of the Rubin report
ever but I'm gonna let you close the
show because you're a pro I want you to
look at that camera right there the one
that's pointed towards you tell them
about no safe spaces where they can go
it's in theaters now the whole spiel I'm
gonna be quiet for the rest take it away
it's in 200 theaters as we speak it's
nationwide as we speak it's 99% on
Rotten Tomatoes with the people that's a
mark of a good thing though it is and
you can go to no safe spaces calm and
find it and really take your kids I mean
take the wife take the husband take the
husband and the wife but take the 13 and
14 year old sons and daughters and let
them know what's going on out there if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell